>> SALMI: My name is Deborah Salmi and I work
in marketing for Web of Trust. Web of Trust
or WOT for short was founded in 2006 by two
university post-graduate students from Finland.
Both worked as researchers in the field of
computer security and data mining. During
their research, they came up with the idea
of creating a reputation system for the web.
The goal was to make the internet a safer
place for everyone, make it more democratic
and to give everyone a chance to contribute
to this objective.
>> What is your extension about?
>> SALMI: The average web user wants to know
which websites they can trust. The WOT add-on
is a safe surfing tool for your browser. It
shows you traffic-light-style rating symbols
that tell you which websites you can trust
for safe surfing, shopping, and searching
on the web. Many experienced users--they want
to contribute to web safety. WOT rating is
powered by a global community of millions
of trustworthy users who've rated millions
of websites based on their experiences.
>> How did your vision evolve as you were
working on your extension?
>> SALMI: We had a clear vision of our extension
from the beginning. This was our third browser
platform. The first version of our extension
used a toolstrip and a mole for its user interface.
But we've had a UI similar to Chrome's browser
actions for years now on other browser platforms.
And we're very happy to see the Chrome team
ultimately decided to go with browser actions
instead.
>> How difficult was it to integrate with
your existing service?
>> SALMI: Well, integration with our existing
service, it was easy. We have a web service
API, and we use HTML HTTP request to access
it from all our other extensions too.
>> What did you enjoy most about writing your
extension?
>> SALMI: We like the fact that it's easy
to reload and test extensions without restarting
the browser. Chrome's developer tools were
a great help in debugging the extension as
well.
>> What were some challenges you faced when
writing your extension?
>> SALMI: We would have liked to see some
additional APIs for cryptographic primitives,
hash functions especially, URL parsing, IDN
conversions for example. So we ended up implementing
these in Java Script instead.
>> Was there a particular technical challenge
you faced in which you gave an innovative
solution?
>> SALMI: Chrome was initially lacking a full
internationalization framework, so we decided
to implement our own because we wanted to
support multiple languages right from the
beginning. So later, the internationalization
framework Chrome team implemented, it was
almost identical to ours. Supporting the extension
to use it was trivial.
>> What do you think about Google Chrome's
decision to use CSS, HTML and JavaScript as
the basis of its extension framework?
>> SALMI: It was brilliant--brilliant decision.
Chrome's move to use HTML, JavaScript and
CSS to create extensions was a brilliant decision,
and it makes developing extensions possible
for anyone with web development experience.
It's a lot easier to develop extensions for
Chrome than for other platforms. Also the
fact that extensions are just web pages, it
gives Chrome a natural way to sandbox them
from each other and from the privileged browser
process.
>> How many times have you updated your extension?
>> SALMI: We've had 12 updates since the initial
release. And updating the extension through
the website, it's really quick and it's convenient.
And we especially like the fact that there's
no need to wait for a human review before
the extension is published to users. So combined
with Chrome's automatic extension updates,
this makes distributing bug fixes and new
features to our users very convenient. And
you know, we've noticed that Chrome users
are far more likely to use the latest version
of our extension than users who have other
browsers.
>> How did you promote your extension?
>> SALMI: Our user community was all a buzz
about Chrome, so when the dev channel and
then later the beta channel was released,
we blogged, we tweeted about it, and many
WOT fans tried it out. And because we made
sure we were one of the first extensions to
be completed for Chrome, many of the respected
tech sites included WOT in the "must-have"
list for Chrome. So now, we are working on
updating our website and featuring WOT for
Chrome more prominently. Part of that is educating
users that they have a choice when it comes
to browsers. But whichever browser they choose,
we want WOT to be part of their safe-surfing
experience.
>> What advice can you give someone before
starting to work on a Google Chrome extension?
>> SALMI: Developers who are starting work
on a Chrome extension, they should carefully
think about the architecture of their extension
and decide early on what they want in the
background page and what should be done in
content scripts. If they plan to localize
the extension, it's a good thing to prepare
for that from the very beginning.
>> Come meet the Web of Trust team, at the
Google IO conference.